[Musique]
bon
alors oui oui bonjour oui je le maire
comment allez vous oui d'accord moi j'ai
compris vous avez toujours autant de
chablis quoi est ce que vous arrivez à
les vendre à peu près depuis 33 ans
michel bourgeois et maire de la petite
commune forestière d'entre deux monts et
ses 142 habitants
alors chaque jour il est confronté de
plein fouet à la crise des scolytes y en
a 20 g forêt de 60000 euros maintenant
on est plutôt à 20000 euros
donc voilà la perte est donc là on est
dans le plan de relance du gouvernement
et puis donc comment on a déjà des
soucis de trésorerie
on peut même pas participé à
l'investissement
les crédits d'investissement diminué
économiquement les communes forestières
s'essouffle il lui à leur tête à
l'échelon départemental en 2014 mais
également régional en 2020 le maire
d'entre deux monts compte alors sur un
plan de relance de la forêt pour mener
efficacement la bataille contre les
scolytes et c'est donc là on est sûr
typiquement sur une forêt mélanger donc
on a des seins train des épicéas des
êtres et donc c'est cette forêt elle est
gérée en futaie jardinée qu'on appelle
c'est à dire que justement on essaye de
garder ces mélanges et on s'est aperçu
en fait que ces forêts par rapport à ces
mélanges d'essence elles sont beaucoup
mieux résiliente à la taille des
scolytes
depuis 1987 et son premier mandat michel
bourgeois voit les choses évoluer si la
forêt au fil du réchauffement climatique
change les prises de conscience et les
politiques commencent elles aussi à
bouger
c'est ce qui a un peu changé aussi dans
dans ces années c'est qu'avant on
s'occupait beaucoup de la production de
la forêt alors que maintenant on
s'occupe bien d'écologie de l'equilibre
forêt gibier de tout ce qui est faux
n'est faune et flore on est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus proche de ses sujets
[Musique]
les sapins du jura un peu moyen ça ça
sent pas sympa on était à la deuxième
fois toujours méteil sont ils m'ont
rappelé pour pouvoir les prendre c'est
pour le sirop on les a rachetés rien
c'est ici à la syrie grandpierre qu'une
partie des grumes des communes
atterrissent à 62 ans
gilles grandpierre est à la tête de
cette entreprise de 20 salariés
mais ce jurassien a dû totalement
repartir de zéro en 2015 une 8 juillet à
châtel de joux sa scierie est victime
d'un terrible incendie dévaste et gilles
ne renonce pas pour autant
et l'année d'après il rachète cette
affaire en banlieue de champagnole j'ai
hésité mais ma fille est venue avec moi
et on a dit on achète pour reconstruire
ici pour repartir ici on a souffert un
peu quand même parce que
il va bien cette série il y avait des
investissements qui avaient pas été
super bien calculé n'était pas adapté
ici il n'avait pas le racheter des
investissements qui permettait de scier
le bois d'ici il modernise alors son
entreprise et achètent plusieurs
machines
[Musique]
chaque jour les grumes sont transportés
sur des rails et sont signés selon des
modèles bien précis cependant les
scieries sont elles aussi confrontées à
l'épidémie des scolytes cette couronne
la double c'est du bleu qui ben en fait
c'est pas acceptée par les négoces et
les utilisateurs ils pensent que c'est
pas bon comme moi même si nous on sait
que structurellement ça pourrait être
bon la présentation ça compte pour
l'instant on n'est pas capable de vendre
ça pour ne pas gaspiller ce bois
gilles grandpierre s'adapte et le thon
rouge afin d'en faire des planches de
signalisation si économie forêts sont
intimement liés l'environnement est une
préoccupation essentielle pour tous les
acteurs de cette forêt des bois qui
regorge d'habitants aux histoires plus
magique les unes que les autres
[Musique]